J'ai réalisé un rêve, je suis allé au Japon.
A Tokyo surtout. Depuis que je suis tout gamin, je rêve d'y aller.
Parce que je... j'adore les paysages.
J'adore les traditions japonaises.
Les temples.
Ah je suis un grand fan de temples.
J'ai ramené plein de trucs de là bas.
Ce qui est bien c'est qu'au Japon,
tu peux trouver des objets qui sont extrêmement pratiques et utiles dans la vie de tous les jours.
Mais que fait mon chat dans un paquet de chips?
Un faux chat dans un paquet de chips.
Extrêmement utile.
Alors avant que je parte, il y a tous mes potes qui sont déjà allés au Japon qui m'ont donné leur petit conseil.
Comme par exemple:
Faut que t'apprennes quelques mots de japonais, hein, ça peut être utile.
Que j'apprenne quelques mots de japonais?
Pour quoi faire, exactement?
Konnichiwa... konnichiwa... c'est tout.
Alors il y a un truc à savoir, c'est que au Japon, les filles se cachent du soleil.
On m'a expliqué que, pour eux, avoir la peau blanche ça signifie la pureté, donc c'est bien vu.
Alors dès qu'il fait beau, elles sortent des ombrelles.
Aie.
Des chaussettes pour les bras.
Normalement il y a des trous pour les doigts.
Et l'accessoire ultime utilisé spécialement par les grand-mères japonaises:
la visière intégrale.
Ce n'est pas une blague... elles ont vraiment ça sur le visage.
Bonjour, belle journée.
Luke, je suis ta grand-mère japonaise.
A Tokyo j'ai croisé des jeunes déguisés en animaux.
Pas pour un événement particulier non non, ils s'habillent comme ça,
en animal,
posés.
Je sors du taf là,
une journée, mais je te raconte même pas, avec la deadline qui approche.
Tu vas au vernissage ce soir?
Non?
Ah t'as un truc, ah bin si t'as un truc...
Alors malheureusement j'ai pas pu tout visiter à Tokyo,
C'est trop grand, j'avais pas assez de temps, il y a des trucs que j'ai dû squeezer.
Comme par exemple:
le musée des algues.
Ah, c'est dommage quand même.
Et directement sur votre droite se trouvent, des algues.
Excusez-moi Monsieur, les photos sont interdites.
Ah vous preniez pas de photo, ah autant pour moi, autant pour moi, j'ai cru que...
C'est des algues quand même, c'est pour ça que...
C'est des algues Monsieur.
C'est des algues!
Je vous paye et vous prenez une photo, allez.
Mais comment parler du Japon sans évoquer les fameuses toilettes japonaises,
qui sont un peu bizarres.
J'ai pas compris pourquoi ils ont intégré un lavabo aux toilettes.
C'est pas très pratique pour boire.